it's a beautiful day to get outside
today because we are losing a lot of
those clouds already and we're starting
to pick up some winds now up in the
northwest valley and out at red rock red
rock just recently had a gust to 18
miles an hour but the northwest valley
up here
close to the centennial hills and sky
canyon areas have had winds uh in the
last hour now 20 to 30 miles an hour so
we're starting to feel those north winds
those will increase seven hills no wind
yet and you just drop to 39 degrees but
pretty much everybody else has been in
the 40s and centennial hills 51 with a
little breeze up there but we're
continuing to feel that wind coming in
with a disturbance across the great
basin it's not bringing rain
and those winds are going to help get
rid of the clouds which are already kind
of thinning out and disappearing these
winds are going to be somewhat out of
the north northeast and you know what
that is that's a santa ana set up for
southern california these are wind
advisories along the coast there in
interior
areas of la county over into orange
county and then along the river and out
to lake mead so the colorado river
valley to lake mead we'll have a wind
advisory that starts at nine o'clock
this morning so just in a couple of
hours all the way till saturday night at
10 p.m gus could get 40 45 miles an hour
in those areas so if you had any plans
for today or even your saturday to be
out along the river or maybe even put
the jet ski on the water or boat or do
some boating plants because people do
that year round here if you're new to
the desert you might think hey it's
winter people shouldn't be boating but
hey lake mead that that's a reality it
is 46 degrees
for mount charleston if you are headed
up to the mountains today there will be
some northeasterly breezes up there as
well to 25 miles an hour that's going to
make things feel extra cool with temps
only in the 40s mid 60s for the valley a
few degrees warmer than yesterday 63
with those overcast skies and generally
winds up to about 25 miles an hour for
the valleys and no wind advisories for
the valley but it's going to be breezy
to bumpy blowing some things around
we'll have low 60s through the weekend
mostly sunny skies winds will be much
calmer for the weekend and through mlk
monday parade time in the morning on
monday should be just fine temps around
50 degrees and then next week we nudge
up a little bit again with lots of good
sunshine to the mid 60s